figaro la ville et 9h25 et nous sommes
en direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre
page youtube figaro live pour commenter
et décrypter ce nouveau chapitre du
procès des attentats du 13 novembre
aujourd'hui mardi 2 novembre
la parole est aux accusés après avoir
entendu les témoignages et les
dépositions des parties civiles la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris va désormais
examiner les profils des accusés leur
parcours leur histoire familiale et
professionnelle leur cv en quelque sorte
ils ne seront pour l'instant pas
interrogé sur les faits sur leur
implication dans les attentats du 13
novembre
alors qui sont ces accusés qui sont ces
quatorze accusés et que peut-on attendre
de cette nouvelle phase du procès nous
allons y répondre dans quelques instants
avec stéphane durand / stéphane durand
souffland chroniqueur judiciaire au
figaro bonjour stéphane dion merci
d'être avec nous ce matin et bonjour à
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent dans lé
chat du figaro.fr et de youtube
n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions et à relayer vos commentaires
je vous lis c'est pour ça que j'ai mon
ordinateur avec moi je relaierai vos
questions et vos commentaires en direct
alors stéphane durand souffland vous
courent vous couvrez ce procès pour le
figaro depuis maintenant près de deux
mois et vous sortez d'un tunnel on peut
appeler ça assez terrible donc
l'audition de toutes les parties civiles
les dépositions qui ont duré cinq
semaines ou les témoins et parties
civiles ont relaté donc cette nuit
d'horreur
comment comment ça s'est passé
ça s'est passé ça s'est bien passé un
point de vue purement technique qui a
pas eu de vague d'incidents il n'y a pas
eu de drame de malaise quelque chose
auquel on peut comme on pouvait le
redouter parce qu'on avait quand même
beaucoup misé sur une sur un moment très
dur émotionnellement donc ça l'a été
c'était éprouvant évidemment avec cette
particularité une des particularités de
ce procès c'est que les parties civiles
c'est aussi les témoins c'est les mêmes
personnes et ce qui est assez rare en
général c'est pas les mêmes personnes
donc là c'est les mêmes donc c'est des
gens qui
avaient souffert
de manière qui dépassent l'entendement
un conte vécu des choses absolument
épouvantable mais qui en même temps
donner des informations très utiles sur
le déroulement des différents attentats
surtout les terrasses et le mas taclant
parce qu au stade de france qu on oublie
souvent d'ailleurs fort injustement ces
trois kamikazes qui se sont fait
exploser à quelques minutes près est il
finalement personne n'a vu grand chose
puisque c'était extrêmement soudains et
sur l'effet même bon y'a pas n'y a pas
grand chose mais ensuite sur les
terrasses y est les rescapés qui ont vu
arriver la voiture descend de lecteurs
qui ont assisté au mitraillage et au
bataclan encore plus puisque l'attentât
du bataclan aussi cette particularité
d'avoir du jury et 2h38 entre
l'irruption des terroristes et là la
libération de tout le monde parle à la
berri
donc voila c'était des moments
évidemment non pour un journaliste
difficile à supporter après on n'est pas
là non plus pour raconter nos petits
bobos qui sont quand même rien du tout à
côté de ce qu'ont vécu les les rescapés
les victimes même s'ils sont plus là
pour le raconter et puis voilà un
chroniqueur judiciaire c'est un métier
qu'on choisit on n'est pas correspondant
guère non plus vous pas trouve qu'on a
beaucoup exagéré
enfin il ya une espèce de tendance à
exagérer la dureté de ces témoignages
quand une fois c'est pas facile à
supporter ça parce que c'est quand même
de l'horreur de l'horreur de l'horreur
de l'horreur pendant des semaines
évidemment que ça ça marque s'apaisent
quand ça pèse mais bon c'est notre
métier c'est de le raconter donc vous
avez une manière de d'encaisser
justement ces horreurs à la chaîne entre
ben non il n'y a pas vraiment de fajac a
fait comme il peut on essaye de
l'écriture de l'article quotidienne
importante pour évacuer plaît prends
ranger soit la vie continue quoi c'est
un travail aussi un c'est vrai que c'est
difficile c'est vrai que c'est difficile
ils n'ont pas on va pas le nier c'est
mais au bout d'un moment je pense qu'on
se d'abord on se raccroche au fait qu'on
est là pour vous raconter pour
transmettre quelque chose pour essayer
de et pas seulement d'ailleurs de
raconter de façon fort ce qui me
concerne très linéaire que ce que
j'entends et ce que je vois mais essayer
de trouver une explication une mise en
perspective en tout cas de ces récits et
ça ça aide à tenir le coup
vous disiez que ce qui était particulier
dans ce procès c'est que les parties
civiles étaient également les témoins
est ce que du coup l'or lors leurs
dépositions était scindé en deux parties
est ce qu'ils étaient interrogés aussi
par des les avocats où il avait la
parole libre comment ça s'est déroulé
alors vous avez la parole libre il n'y
avait pas la partie témoin la partie
partie civile il doit dire poser une
difficulté procès comme il y aurait
fallu qu'un moment la partie civile ça
arrête de faire la partie civile prêté
serment et deviennent témoin ce qui
était resté bien on n'a pas vraiment de
sens puisque c'est vraiment une
quelque chose de
très intime qui ont vécu chacun à sa
façon c'est ça qui est intéressant dans
l'histoire c'est que chaque personne
et on retrouve plein d'éléments communs
dans tous ces récits notamment au
bataclan
ça commence toujours par j'étais à tel
endroit il ya un plan qui est projeté le
rescapé pointe avec un petit pointeur
laser dit voilà j'étais là et tout d'un
coup j'ai entendu des bruits j'ai cru
que c'était des pétards en général ça
commence comme ça mais une espèce de la
production commune et puis après chacun
a vécu quelque chose
de différent c'est la même chose mais
c'est chaque fois un récit différent
donc on a
on a honte et c'est tout ça est donc
cette
restitution de
le mot douleur n'était pas assez de
sidération de choses de ce moment où la
personne se rend compte qu'elle est en
train de vivre un attentat du côté des
balles qui partent et de lutter pour ne
pas mourir d'essayer de se cacher de
fuir et donc là on embraye sur le
témoignage parce que beaucoup beaucoup
ont vu les terroristes donc 3 et t3
certains ont cru qu un avec 4 et que le
croit encore alors que rien ne permet de
l'établir ce qu'on a retrouvé ensuite
alors sauf à penser qu'un terroriste se
serait échappée au milieu d'eux
des chanceux entre mille mais qui ont pu
très vite emprunté une issue de secours
a priori gt3 et certains les ont vus
beaucoup les ont vus certains leur ont
parlé eu des échanges c'est ça qui est
très vertigineux dans cette histoire
c'est qu'on a trois hommes qui sont en
train de commettre un massacre
absolument sans précédent avec une
décontraction
sidérante les récits sont un des
rescapés 10 et il s'amusait à tuer donc
s'amuser à tuer c'est plus de 2 de
liesse meurtrière à 3
qu'on s'arrête donc des récits du
bataclan c'est le bal d'accord alors
c'est vrai qu'on focalise beaucoup sur
bataclan parce que parce que ça a duré
très longtemps et c'est vrai que c'est
pas parce que c'est plus grave il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas d'attenté plus grave
qu'à nous tous on pouvait entame mais
les terrasses étaient des mitraillages
éclaire la voiture s'arrêtait les trois
terroristes sortait vider leur chargeur
et repartait ça durait deux minutes une
minute 32 minutes donc les gens étaient
totalement pris de court qui sont à
jeter par terre mba pas vu grand chose
en général pour ça que les témoignages
du bataclan sont beaucoup plus est riche
sur un
contenu puisque ça a duré longtemps et y
ait eu des échanges verbaux avec les
avec certains otages et les preneurs
d'otages
alors lors d'un précédent direct sur
figaro l'ajustement réalisé en tout
début des auditions des parties civiles
avec charlotte barrio vous aviez dit
qu'en tant que journaliste vous
attendiez au pire pour ce procès est ce
que pour l'instant le pire est arrivé ou
ça se déroule comme vous l'aviez peu
près espère que le pire est passé de
pierre est passé oui c'est encore une
fois c'est évidemment que c'est propre
c'est toujours éprouvant dans une cour
d'assises doit entendre la parole d'un
rescapé ou d'une victimes ou de proches
de victimes toujours mais dans un procès
classique il y en a une une famille ils
ont 3 4 la spécificité évidemment c'est
qu'il y en a des centaines il ya des
centaines de rescapés il ya des
centaines qui chacune chacun des
rescapés à une famille donc dans
certains cas ça fait beaucoup de
témoignages pour une personne plusieurs
témoignages donc bon
c'était c'était particulier la main
maintenant l'expérience est hors norme
vous remarquerez maintenant que tous les
procès concours sont hors normes je
trouvais ça ne c'est devenu un mot qui
n'a plus aucun sens donc ce procès est
pour moi démesuré c'est sans commune
mesure avec tout ce qu'on connaît
il est très dur mais j'en ai vécu
d'autres c'est très très dur alors avec
cette spécificité ici que il ya le grand
nombre de personnes bouleversées et
parfois dont on peut se demander s'ils
vont à jean sortir de ce cauchemar est
ce qu'un témoignage en particulier ou
une déposition qui vous a plus marqué je
vais vous dire que je veux pas répondre
à cette question puisque justement une
des questions qu'on se pose je crois
tous autant qu'on est un chroniqueur
judiciaire c'est qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est
ce qu'on retient pourquoi on va prendre
le témoignage de cette jeune femme
parce que ea prévoit là on prend cette
jeune femme est pas ce monsieur mars que
cette jeune femme
ils essaient vraiment
parce que cette jeune femme s'exprime
très bien chez qu'elle trouve des mots
extraordinaire qu'elle a des formules
magnifique qu'elle est très belle ou
qu'il est très beau enfin briller il ya
une espèce de l'ensemble qui fait que
naturellement on va se s'attacher à ça
mais moi j'ai été par exemple
extrêmement
le touché par les témoignages des
victimes du stade de france
dont on parle peu encore une fois et
c'est drôle enfin c'est drôle c'est que
c'est cocasse il a une espèce aussi de
sociologie de la victime dans ce procès
on a au stade de france des victimes qui
sont originaires de deux classes
populaires des gens
de milieux modestes qui viennent la soie
pour beaucoup de gens d'origine serbe
qui était là parce qu' une petite un
petit groupe de gens qui vendent des
écharpes et des zags des gadgets pour
les supporteurs de football qui avait le
fameux match france-allemagne ce soir
donc c'est des gens vraiment très
modeste qui s'expriment pas très bien
qui vont parfois donner des détails un
peu un peu gênant un peu embarrassant
sur sur ce qui s'est passé mais ces gens
ils ont été que pour certains criblés de
d'écrou ils ont vu un proche gravement
blessé certains ont vu le malheureux il
ya eu un mort au stade de france à
monsieur danger une portugaise certains
l'ont vu déchiquetés c'est des gens qui
vont payer au stade de france on a des
gens qui vont manger au mcdo parce que
c'est la sortie vont au mcdo en seine
saint denis et puis sur les terrasses on
a des gens de
bobos qui vont en terrasse avec leurs
copains et ils sont architectes
designers
journalistes et s'exprime beaucoup mieux
donc tous les témoignages pense il faut
il faut je pense qu'il faut accepter
l'idée que tous ces témoignages
sont dignes d'être reçu écoutez de la
même manière et tous il y en a pas un
qui finit pas par nous toucher il ya le
problème aussi des témoignages les
personnes qui sont vindicative parce que
sur les cons bien entendu en tout
j'aurais peut-être tout compris 400 ou
500 vous n'avez pas à citer aucun nom
mais moi je n'étais pas tous mais voilà
parmi ceux ci
dans leur immense majorité s'est déjà
extrêmement calme qui ne manifestent pas
de haine
au contraire ça qu'ils sont dans une
espèce de démarche extrêmement
qui cherche la sérénité est pas la n va
dire ça comme ça mais dans le lot on a
quelques uns qui sont très rares qui eux
sont très remontés et qui sont très
haineux à l'égard des accusés des
islamistes en général et des accusés en
particulier
et ça ça pose un problème parce que il
nous embarrasse d'une certaine manière
fait honnête on aime bien c'était moins
parties civiles qui sont dignes qui qui
qui professent des idées extrêmement
noble qui ont pétri d'humanité c'est
vrai que c'est bouleversant mais il ya
aussi ces quelques personnes qui sont
très rares très rares qui qui accuse
alors l'état qui accuse qui quittent qui
tiennent des des propos un peu
complotistes ce qui se serait passé au
bataclan alors qu'on sait que ça ne
s'est pas passé et notamment des scènes
de torture qui aurait eu lieu certains
très peu certains proches des victimes
sont persuadés que leurs proches a été
horriblement torturé avec les cadavres
mutilés auto etc on sait que c'est pas
vrai et on sait depuis hier façon on le
sait parce qu'on n'a pas retrouvé
d'armes blanches déjà là et qu'on a
toujours trouvé ça veut dire que le
bataclan a été nettoyée il n'y a pas un
millimètre carré qui a échappé aux
pinceaux des
scientifiques dont on appartient et puis
surtout on a des centaines de témoins
donc ya des centaines de personnes qui
disent tout qu'il n'y en a pas eu un
nombre et donc ces deux témoignages là
ils font ils font tache dans une espèce
de deux grandes
de grands moments de l'humanité mais
c'est aussi de l'humanité il faut les
prendre comme tel faux pas les cacher
les existe comme ça et on peut pas
demander on peut pas exiger d'un père
dont la fille est morte boitaclous sur
une terrasse on peut pas exiger de lui
qu'il soit une espèce de saint françois
d'assise quoi c c'est aussi humain tout
ça et j'imagine que il arrive avec le ce
qu'ils ont envie de dire est que à aucun
moment ni la cour ni personne ne sait ce
qu'ils vont dire c'est alors c'est un
peu brut la course est un peu parce que
souvent ces personnes ont été entendues
avant d'accord donc en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les rescapés ils ont été
entendus sur les familles ont certains
on peut savoir parce que certains se
sont parlés déjà aux médias donc on
s'est un peu la course est un peu à quoi
s'attendre et le rôle du président c'est
de faire en sorte que si les gens en
colère exprimée bas qui expriment leur
colère leur haine mais jusqu'à un
certain point on peut pas dans une cour
d'assises
injurié
les accusés ou leurs avocats qu'ils
prennent souvent aux passagers en plus
géographiquement entre les deux est
souvent aussi on les accuse de défendre
des monstres et c est là le président
intervient ce moment là je veux pas
aller trop loin justement j'ai une
citation du président de la cour
monsieur période qui avait déclaré
sûrement à la suite d'une personne qui
simple qui ça inquiète invectivé
directement la défense
en leur disant vous êtes nombreux à vous
adresser aux accusés je rappelle juste
qu'il bénéficie de la présomption
d'innocence et que pour nombre d'entre
eux ils contestent leur participation
aux faits est ce que je sais c'est une
question que j'avais à vous poser est ce
que le dialogue entre une victime ou un
proche une famille et un accusé est
possible dans ce genre de procès est ce
que le président aurait pu laisser un
dialogue si l'un des accusés était
ouvert au dialogue si tenté que c'était
possible
dans une cour d'assises tout est
possible c'est un espace à la fois
extrêmement réglementé ritualisé est
très ouvert puisque le procès d'assises
repose sur l'oralité des débats est le
contradictoire c'est vraiment les deux
piliers c'est l'oralité qui compte plus
que le dossier en principe donc le
président doit savoir à ses lacs c'est à
ça qu'on le juge qu'on voit si c'est un
bon président doit savoir jusqu'où il
peut permettre par exemple un échange
c'est possible théoriquement c'est
extrêmement risqué évidemment il faut
pas que ça tourne à la foire d'empoigné
l échange d'injures mais c'est possible
dans les cordes au fait j'ai déjà vu des
dialogues entre une partie civile et
l'accusé s'est parfois extrêmement
déroutant j'ai juste apparemment procès
de tueur en série guy georges ou des
familles de victimes se sont directement
adressés à lui et il a répondu oui
c'est très curieux mais si c'est
ça peut déboucher sur quelque chose on
peut pas l'exclure maintenant évidemment
tout dépend de la situation dit j'en
sais rien à voir mais
georges à ce moment là il avait admis sa
participation il avait il avait reconnu
sa culpabilité donc on s'adressait aux
coupables
revendiquer la dans le cadre de ce
procès c'est plus compliqué puisque les
d'abord pour l'instant on ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'ils vont les accusés
vont pas reconnaître certains ont
reconnu certaines choses notamment pas
je pense à ceux qui ont reconnu qu'ils
étaient venus chercher
abdeslam à paris c'était mieux de
belgique qui l'avait ramenée à bruxelles
ont eux ils l'ont reconnu donc mais tout
en disant qu'il ignorait il ignorait ce
qu'il avait fait donc le débat va être
de savoir s'il l'ignoré ou pas mais ces
gens là on peut leur demander qui ont
péri mais n'avez pas honte d'avoir fait
ça bon maintenant abdeslam lui a été
arrêtée on sait qu'il était le 13
novembre 2015 à paris avec un gilet
explosif qu'il n'a pas utilisé pour des
raisons alors la plus mystérieuse
m'enfin bon quand on est à paris le 13
novembre 2015 à kg d'explosifs c'est un
peu compliqué de dire qu'on était au
courant de rien qu'on passait là par
hasard maintenant il ya tous les autres
il y en a un par exemple un des accusés
reconnaît avoir fourni des faux papiers
ou à plusieurs des terroristes ou de au
réseau mais il dit qu'il ignorait
totalement et qui pensaient que c'était
cinquante droit commun donc la cour
devra établir s'il savait ou non que
c'était pour des crimes terroristes lui
jure que non donc plus c'est compliqué
de discuter avec lui
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
toujours en direct sur lefigaro.fr et
sur notre page youtube figaro live pour
expliquer vous expliquer les enjeux de
cette ce nouveau chapitre du procès des
attentats du 13 novembre qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui on va donc donc revenir à
l'actualité de ce procès
aujourd'hui démarre donc l'examen de
personnalité des 14 accusés qui sont
présents dans la cour d'assises spéciale
de paris est ce que c'est une étape
essentielle du procès
si oui en quoi sa nuit alors que
l'examen de personnalité c'est une étape
une étape obligatoire du procès dans
tous les procès un moment on examine la
personnalité de l'accusé donc le
président quand il fait son plein il n'a
pas le choix il faut y passer et ils
décident de le faire soit avant soit
après l'examen des faits là il est donc
décidé de le faire avant et donc ils
sont quatorze présente sur l'a6 qui ne
sont pas là 1,5 qui sont sans doute
morts dans la zone irak ou au syrienne
est un qui est détenu en turquie
actuellement on a 14
il ya une singularité par contre deux
dans les procès des terroristes
islamistes en l'occurrence qui est assez
curieuse c'est que on sépare de la
personnalité tout ce qui concerne la
religion dire que le
l'engagement dans l'islam la croyance la
pratique tout ça ne sera pas abordée au
moment de la personnalité mais plus tard
au moment des faits c'est une règle un
peu particulière c'est dans tous les
procès dans tout l'est parce que c'est
comme ça ah je pensais que cet écueil
dans cette ville par exemple au procès
d'abdelkader meira souvient le frère de
mohamed merah le locker le transfère
islamistes de toulouse il y avait les
avait été précisées dès le début et
parfois évidemment des avocats essayé au
moment de la personnalité de
l'interroger là dessus et l'accusé
lui-même qui était tout sauf idiot non
mais monsieur le président a dit que ce
serait vu plus tard donc il ya cette
espèce de
de séparation entre assez arbitraire et
un peu artificielle entre l'engagement
religieux d'un individu et
sa personnalité donc là on va être sur
la personnalité c'est à dire la vie
comme on dit le parcours de vie donc la
naissance la famille les frères les
soeurs les parents les études le travail
les loisirs la vie amoureuse
toutes ces choses sont
son sont abordés alors là où est ce que
je constate c'est que ça dure pas
longtemps du tout cela on a une semaine
pour ça ils sont quatorze donc selon
vous laisse voir le temps qui est prévu
pour chacun d'entre eux pas beaucoup
c'est un des arguments de la défense
d'ailleurs de salade et cela me dire que
quatre jours c'est trop court moi ça me
paraît très court d'un point de vue
mathématique ce véritable des
personnalités assez sommaire alors
maintenant reste à savoir ce que c'est
quatorze ont envie de dire 2 je pense
que le
l'accusé qui le suffisante on parle tout
à l'heure celui qui accuse qui ai
envoyés ici pour les faux papiers qui
s'appelle carter je pense que lui aura
plus le coeur a parlé de sa famille de
sa femme de ses enfants et ses 1 qu'un
sale abdeslam qui a déclaré dès le début
juin combattants d'âge et je pense qu'on
va voir c'est tout à l'heure on commence
dont les prendre en fabrique ans
pratiquent donc ça commence par salle
abdeslam peut-être que ça abdeslam une
fois qu'il a dit je suis un combattant
d'esch et a tout dit c'est peut-être sa
salle abdeslam incombe à tanda et g puis
tout le reste
ce qu'on voit souvent dans le nom dedans
avec les terroristes islamistes et que
le moment de la conversion de l'islam
alors le soin de rien du tout al islam
radical soit d'un islam modéré un islam
radical ce moment la marque un
changement de personnalité c'est à dire
un rejet de toute sa vie
davant
parlant des délinquants souvent sur des
petits délinquants ou des gros
délinquants d'ailleurs qu'ils deviennent
des islamistes et on constate que à
partir du moment où ils passent dans
cette catégorie là il tourne le dos
complètement leur vie d'avant c'est à
dire que ils arrêtent de 10 les lézards
est de terroriser leurs mères leurs
soeurs et leurs frères et contraire et
deviennent assez doux parce qu'ils sont
partis dans un on avait vu ça je pense
pour mohamed merah ils sont partis dans
un chemin qui va les mener aux martyrs
donc ils savent que leur vie terrestre
est sur le point de s'achever donc avant
de partir il se met un peu en ordre avec
tout le monde est ce que justement vous
pouvez tout faire et les familles
mohamed merah mais est ce que les
familles sont attendues oui certains
doit entendre des proches c'est
obligatoire ou pas les normes
obligatoires ils peuvent ne pas venir
aussi je pense que là qui voudront pas
revenir
après ce que c'est très c'est toujours
pareil c'est
le
la richesse de ce qu'on va récolter va
dépendre de la générosité des orateurs
s'ils veulent pas on peut pas forcer
quelqu'un parler de ses années d'école
ou de ces de ces conditions beaucoup ont
été condamné déjà pour des affaires de
droit commun de parfois pas là mais
parfois plus plus long après il peut le
dire moi j'ai payé ma dette fini tout ça
est alors de jeunesse oui et puis c'est
difficile de parler de soi si on se rend
pas compte à laon tu ne dis pas ça du
tout apitoyer sur le sort des accusés
dont certains ont des profils
extrêmement inquiétant elles sont
présumés tous innocents bien sûr
certains des 16 des chaussures qui sont
très inquiétantes mais parler de soi
c'est pas un exercice facile alors le
aussi le ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est
que les accusés sont présumés innocents
mais ils ont le droit de mentir aussi ne
prête pas serment ce n'est pas comme aux
états unis ont témoigné sur un serment
sur la bible la nuit sur la ville ni sur
aucun écrit religieux donc ils ont droit
de mentir mentir sur son cv c'est un peu
un peu ballot parce qu'en général il a
été retracée très soigneusement à
l'instruction on sait les grandes lignes
et en plus c'est pas forcément très
intéressant non plus la banalité ça peut
être aussi quelque chose d'intéressant
dans un parc au mais pour pour
comprendre parce que
ce qu'on nous dit toujours c'est que ça
va nous permettre de comprendre de
comprendre de comprendre de comprendre
donc si on veut comprendre il faut
essayer de voir la trajectoire des deux
comme on part de là milieu modeste à
molenbeek dans une famille on a des
copains machin truc dans un quartier
modeste de la banlieue de bruxelles
d'ailleurs pas de la banlieue russie a
cessé un quartier bruxelles à se
retrouver le 13 novembre avec un lilas
explosifs pendant que ses copains
pendant que son frère va se faire
exploser au comptoir voltaire et que les
que soi même on n'expose pas et ça on
attend beaucoup de sa lame qui nous
l'expliquent c'est surtout cette
question
vous pensez que
ben on va rien apprendre sûr sûr sûr sûr
cette histoire donc pourquoi il n'a pas
activé alors il ya deux versions soit il
l'a pas activé soit il la cuvée mais ça
n'a pas fonctionné le seule chose qu'on
sait puisque ce juge ait été retrouvés
et expertisés par des experts
artificiers on sait qu'il était mal
conçu qu'un problème de fonctionnement
mais il était mal fichu donc mais on ne
peut pas dire s'il a été actionnée et
que ça n'a pas marché ou s'il n'a pas
été clair on sait qu'il était défectueux
on sait qu'ils n'auraient probablement
pas pété s'il avait tiré le le
détonateur voilà c'est tout ce qu'on
sait et s'il faut pas en attendre je
crois aussi on focalise beaucoup sur ces
personnalités évidemment sur salade et
slam puisque s'adapter cela mais le seul
terroriste
retrouver vivants des commandos du 13
novembre tous les autres sur noir soit
ils sont faits exposés soit ils ont été
tués par la police donc il ya que lui
qui pourrait dire des choses jusqu'à
présent il n'a rien dit
à vue de nez on me demande bien pourquoi
ils viendraient là à prévoir des chemins
combattante d'âge est ce qu'on a fait
c'était normal puisque vous avez attaqué
nos frères et nos soeurs donc nous on
est mieux en riposte on voit pas très
bien on le dit magyd mal entrés dans une
espèce de contrition des banques et je
vais tout vous dire maintenant après
tout est possible mais il y en a
d'autres qui sont très intéressants
notamment son son voisin de box abri
nick est un ami d'enfance à lui et qui
est aussi un homme qui est un un élément
apparemment d'après l'accusation très
important du dispositif et lui a
sûrement beaucoup de choses à raconter
si l'accusation dit vrai ce serait
intéressant cabrini nous parle un peu de
son de son parcours en plus il pourrait
nous parler de la des slams puisqu'il ne
connaît plus l'enfant est ce que
d'ailleurs abri ni a parlé déjà durant
ses premiers mois ou pas du tout il n'y
a que salade et slam qui a qui a pris la
parole lors de l'ouverture du procès
dans une des possibles des singularités
de ce procès c'est que la parole des
accusées jusqu'à présent est extrêmement
rare versé leur procès mais on les
entend pas on les a entendus
le premier jour se levait et oui je suis
bien cette personne est même les avocats
sont là on les a attendus on les a
entendus très brièvement un moment le
président a fait un tour de boxe assez
rapide pour demandant à chacun de sa
position sur les faits donc certains ont
dit moi je j'ignorais totalement ce qui
était en train de se passer certains
comme abdeslam
abdeslam et je suis un combattant de
beige certain a dit je reconnais certes
certaines choses mais pas d'autres et
d'autres ont dit pour l'instant je ne
parle pas je j'attends plus tard pour
m'exprimer donc on sait on est encore
dans un flou c'est incroyable ce
procédure et lui et à commencer par dont
le 8 septembre
et on entendra les accusés sur le fond
c'est sur les charges qui pèsent sur eux
qu'au mois de janvier 2022 mais on est
un procès extrêmement dilater dans le
temps tout et tout dilatés et tirer ça
on n'a pas le côté un peu sec des
assises où
chaque jour et ce choix là là on a eu
cet été une très très longue séquence de
parties civiles qui avec un peu figé les
choses
dans cet aspect là du crime mais sur le
fait sur les fêtes on aura des paroles
d'accuser que en janvier après les fêtes
il y aura une coupure d'un coureur il ya
une suspension de 15 jours pour eux et
on attaquera le vif du sujet là en
janvier et justement pendant ces cinq
semaines où ils ont dû écouter à la
barre les témoignages difficile et c est
ce que qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce
qu'il a transparu de leur attitude a pas
grand chose qui lui révèleront d'abord
on a une difficulté pour
répondre parce que la cour d'assises a
été constaté une cour d'assises
spécialement
construite aussi spécialement composées
et spécialement édifié puisque elle a
été construite dans le palais de justice
on a fait un grand grande très grande
salle d'audience
c'est vraiment au le gars est immense et
donc les accusés sont très loin de nous
deux des bancs de la présent avec voix
mais son roman loin et donc en plus il
porte un masque donc on ne sait pas on
ne peut pas savoir exactement ce qui
alors nous nos confrères dessinateur qui
eux sont beaucoup plus près d'eux les
voies
apparemment ils sont sûrs ils tiennent
très bien failli a pas eu de il n'y a
pas eu d'incident y en a un qui a fait
un petit malaise un jour mais c'est vrai
que c'est la condition de l'accusé n'est
pas enviable on l'élève très tôt enfin
il y à prémont et y sont transférées
c'est compliqué il ya beaucoup de temps
d'attentes un déjeuner un peu
approximatif voilà donc parfois le
stress tout ça peut peut conduire un
petit une petite différence qui était
sans gravité mais ya pas eu de une ou
deux fois abdeslam comme vous l'avez
tous vu s'élever pour éructer quelques
protestations que harangue à face et
reste extrêmement limitée n'y a pas de
quoi en plus ça avait le mérite de la
franchise 1 au moins on pourra reprocher
plein de jose abdeslam mais pas de
pratiquer ce que vous savez la taqiyya
le fameux argument un peu un peu valise
qui permet de dire à chaque fois qu'un
cas quelqu'un avec remy est accusé d'un
crime terroriste islamiste de dix
rebelles n'en sont pas moins des oui
c'est la taqiyya c'est la ruse faire
croire que pour armand abdeslam n'est
plus un adepte de la taqiyya puisqu'il
revendiqué dès le début comme combattant
d'âge
j'avais une question mais peut-être ça
concerne pas forcément ce procès mais
est-ce que c'est dans le cas des
entretiens de personnalités que
la défense peut jouer sur la carte de la
folie de son client ou pas du tout ça
parce que c'est dans ce cadre que des
expertises psychiatriques sont
normalement emmenées dans un procès pour
terrorisme
j'imagine que nous dans un autre procès
aux assises c'est à ce moment là qu'on
peut jouer la carte de la faute aux
assises leur expertise psychiatrique est
obligatoire tous les personnes toutes
les personnes renvoyées en cour
d'assises doivent rencontrer un expert
psychiatre mais sont peu oublié de lui
répondre alors je ne sais pas j'avoue
franchement j'ai un trou de mémoire je
ne sais pas si abdeslam n'a pas refusé
l'expertisé catry qui en a le droit bon
mais de toute façon
donc l'argument de la folie n'est jamais
avancé à ce stade là il ya parfois des
crimes commis
par des types qui crient allah akbar et
qui avec qui ils sortent dans la rue
avec un couteau qui blessent ou qui
tuent des gens c'est arrivé on se rend
compte que ces personnes ont par exemple
des antécédents psychiatriques lourds
donc on s'interroge valeur voilà leur
discernement au moment du passage à
l'acte cette question ne s'est pas posé
à aucun moment dans l'ue dans des
attentats de 2015 que ce soit sur
personne ne s'est jamais demandé si les
frères kwasi n'était pas un peu dérangé
personne donc c'est aussi un argument
qu'on entend parfois dit oui on va leur
trouver des excuses sont fous ils sont
pas fous d'ailleurs les fous au sens de
l'article 122-1 du code pénal ne sont
pas renvoyés aux assises si si si l'un
d'eux a été
une abolition du discernement au moment
des faits il n'aurait pas été renvoyé
donc tous ces gens sont là parce qu'ils
sont sains d'esprit et ça se voit
combattants des îles ici n'y souscrivent
des pistons et son discours très
choquant évidemment mais très cohérent
n'a pas l'impression d'être face à un
illuminé way qui entend des voix ou qui
n'est plus lui-même ou qu'il ya des
doublements il est tous pour ce qu'on en
a vu jusqu'à présent sont nés des hommes
sains d'esprit au sens médical du terme
stéphane durand souvent est ce que vous
pouvez dire rapidement d'un mode et des
autres accusés on a parlé un petit peu
de salles abdeslam et de moimbé des
abris ni mais il y en a donc douze
autres est-ce qu'ils sont un peu tous
dans le même panier ou évidemment
appliqué à les deux moines maintenant
ils sont pas tous dans le même panier de
mes moyens à six qui encourt la
perpétuité
dont un seul abdeslam voir la perpétuité
réelle qui existe contrairement à ce
qu'on dit souvent il ya ça existe la
perpétuité réelle c'est une des mesures
parti qui doivent être prises de manière
particulière au moment du verdict et
kiki defacto empêche toute demande de
libération conditionnelle jusqu'à la fin
de la peine c'est de la mort
donc ça existe un exemple michel
fourniret a été condamné en son temps à
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
dite réelle et bons éléments comme vous
le savez en prison mais était beaucoup
plus âgée
donc les autres il il ya plusieurs jeux
pas entraînés à leur patronyme que j'ai
peur d'écorcher et je ne pratique pas
beaucoup mais il ya des profils allant
vous avez
dans le lot il ya ce ce
sept accusés des faux papiers qui me
paraît très intéressant parce que lui
n'était pas répertorié comme
l'ulm en pratiquant même c'est un petit
voyou apparemment qui faisait du trafic
de faux papiers etc a d'ailleurs utilisé
un réseau de droit commun pour pour
fournir le réseau terroriste en faux
papiers donc lui il est intéressant car
car il ya eu un autre qui est très
intéressant c'est le frère de les
commanditaires qui s'appelle athar qui
était le commanditaire en syrie des
attentats son petit frère est là et lui
sa ligne de défense est à dire je suis
là parce que
moi mais datar et monfreid mais moi je
ne suis pas moi ma nature je suis ni sa
famille sauf si ma mémoire est bonne et
je prie de m'excuser mais comment les a
peu entendu encore gmail engin peut on
les fait on peut voir les procès que les
plus d'accuser le fait de les voir
parler ça permet de les identifier
surtout quand ils ont masqué et très
loin donc ce sera tard la lui dit qu'il
n'est pour rien et les charges contre
lui ont l'air on va dire un peu plus un
peu moins solide que contre d'autres
après il y en a dans le lot il ya un
excellent wissman qui est un artiste est
né lui qui est venu et qui faisait
apparemment partie qui devait faire
partir de commandos pour frapper en
europe donc on va dire qu'il est assez
mal engagée
ça va être en tous cas beaucoup plus
difficile pour sa défense
il y en a un alors qu'un projet
extrêmement inquiétant qui s'appelle
kraiem 8 un suédois
d'origine et les suédois r je crois et
lui il est il était en syrie il a fait
partie des combattants de neige en syrie
et on le
l'accusation soutient que sur une vidéo
de propagande des shs où on voit des
combattants de l'unité d'élite de neige
la barre dans les zones de combat
brûlé vif un pilote jordanien qu'ils
avaient capturé il l'avait mis dans une
cage et l'on brûlé vif d'après
l'accusation on voit ce kraiem parmi les
combattants le doj qui sont ils se
réjouissent de ceux de ce crime
abominable
la preuve matérielle contre lui voilà
donc je sais pas alors on connaît pas
encore sa position là dessus je pense
que ça sera évoquée il y a abri nick est
en effet très intéressant qu'on appelle
l'homme au chapeau parce que lui on le
voit sur les vidéos lors d'un attentat
qui a eu lieu au printemps 2016 à
l'aéroport de bruxelles on le voit avec
deux autres kamikazes
dans l'aéroport les autres les kamikazes
ont fait exploser mais pas lui et bruni
était à paris juste avant les attentats
c'est un ami d'enfance de la baisse la
voilà c'est un personnage aussi sans
doute très intéressante al alors vous
avez vous l'avez évoqué plusieurs fois
la couverture de ce procès la couverture
médiatique va durer neuf mois un petit
peu feuilletonner avec plusieurs étapes
essentielles certains internautes ou
citoyens critiques du coup le côté un
peu spectacle de ce traitement d'une
actualité pourquoi il est quand même
nécessaire de couvrir l'intégralité de
ce procès
d'abord on est en vie dans une
démocratie et quand on attrape des gens
qu'on accuse de crimes on les juge donc
après
qu'on ait que ce soit un viol dans un
bois où des attentats de novembre 2
1015 évidemment il ya en proportion au
rapatriement le rapport mais n'empêche
que ces gens on les accuse de choses
terribles donc on nous les juges selon
nos nos lois et ne ne pas les juger ce
serait d'une certaine manière a indiqué
devant le théorise qu'est ce qu'on en
ferait sinon la réussite je sais pas ce
qu on voit beaucoup sur les réseaux des
gens qui disent une balle dans la tête
un bon c'est une conception
de la vie un jeu pas la commenter mais
c'est pas la mienne en tout cas et moi
je pense que les
on a une justice on a des règles des
règles de droit ces gens sont accusés
ils ont droit de se défendre et sont
représentés par font plusieurs avocats
de certains sont bons avocats enfin bon
c'est à ce qu'on appelle un procès
équitable
donc cours duquel ils pourront se faire
entendre alors leurs proches du
spectacle moi je le comprends assez mal
c'est depuis du chroniqueur judiciaire
fait vingt ans maintenant donc je dis
récurrent c'est toujours mais ça coûte
de l'argent mais gna gna mais ça leur
donne la parole ils font leur propagande
vont nous coûter on verra toute façon
pour l'instant les a pas entendus mais
ça coûte de l'argent oui ça coûte de
l'argent en effet ça coûte de l'argent
ça coûte de l'argent de dédommager aussi
les parties civiles qui viennent de loin
de de mobiliser d'importantes forces de
sécurité pour pour faire de l'île de la
cité où se trouve le palais de justice
une espèce de deals imprenable oui c'est
ça coûte des moyens mais
c'est quoi l'autre solution c'est encore
on les met dans une cage on les brûle
enfin oui et
après ce métier d'être chronique
deuxième et je ne comprends pas ce
reproche je ne vois pas comment on peut
déplorer qu'un état démocratique
organisé un procès équitable pour pour
des gens qui ont voulu détruire la
république d'une certaine manière on a
jugé
est un as
la guerre pour des faits de
collaboration n'a pas misé contre un mur
oui on est parent souvenez vous la
révolution qu'on mène le procès fantoche
des déchets ou geste qu'on fait tout ça
évidemment ce rapport mais la justice
expéditive n'est pas une justice donc on
nous on a une justice
justice d'un état de droit d'une
démocratie on a un code on applique les
règles et on applique à tous
justement dans le chat de youtube donc
darus xérès qui partagent donc ces
critiques que je vous soumettez à quoi
sert cette mascarade les mettre à la
barre pour une mise en scène médiatique
aucun respect des victimes franchement
et aurélie gallard qui dit non on les
fout antho la vie voilà on à la tonalité
effectivement de ce que vous disiez et
beaucoup de d'internautes du figaro
justement comme christian léon toussaint
sur lefigaro.fr qui dit ce devrait être
un tribunal militaire qui les juge
alors sur le respect des victimes et
évidemment je partage pas du tout ce que
cette appréciation
les moins qu'on vient de passer montre
qu'il ya respect des victimes
extrêmement marqué à ce procès dire
qu'on leur donne le temps de parole
nécessaire qu'elle souhaite prendre pour
s'exprimer et on de rap ou à aucun
moment on a dit bon s'il vous plaît
abrégé faire que certains parlent un peu
longtemps on les écoute donc le mais le
procès pénal c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas une cabine et psychanalyse c'est pas
un truc de réparation c'est c'est un
procès pénal se conjuguent des accusés
donc les parties civiles alors place à
tenir là-dedans elle la tienne et on les
respecte d'ailleurs
oui après tribunal militaire alors
faudrait faudrait alors qu'un tribunal
militaire ça voudrait dire qu'on était
en temps de guerre et que que l'état
islamique est un vrai et avec une vraie
armée mais non c'est le terroriste donc
c'est pas des bons c'est tous pour moi
c'est qu'ils pensent que ces réflexions
ne sont pas fondées une autre réflexion
de christophe de marle sur lefigaro.fr
l'état de droit la justice sont
totalement inefficaces face à des
fanatiques de cette espèce le seul
intérêt
de ce procès c'est la catharsis
je voulais raconter remis du coup sûr
une sur une dernière question stéphane
les quelles sont les prochaines étapes
on va dire importante de ce procès donc
là on va suivre évidemment donc ces
auditions enfin ces interrogatoires des
accusées jusqu'à la fin de la semaine et
puis après quel chapitre s'ouvre alors
après on va avoir une autre séquence un
peu composite où il y aura d'une part
des exposés de sachant comme on dit sur
le terrorisme islamiste d'âge la syrie
et l'irak donc là on va avoir des
experts de la dgsi on va avoir des des
experts du contre espionnage mais aussi
du contre-espionnage des services bell
du service autrichien c'est une enquête
à n'oublions pas que c'est une enquête
quand même internationale donc des
experts qui vont venir apporter leur
lumière sur le phénomène global et puis
des grands témoins si on peut appeler ça
comme ça qui sont notamment françois
hollande qui a été cité par la partie
civile on peut toujours se demander ce
que françois hollande va pouvoir nous
dire d'intéressant qu'il n'aurait pas
déjà dit redit et sereine et mille fois
depuis les faits qu'ils auraient droit à
dire sur tout alors alors après voilà
découvert il ya des choses qui ne peut
pas dire mais je pense que je pense que
bon une d1 des arguments qui est avancé
pour légitimer sa citation comme témoin
c'est de dire que la revendication des
crimes il est dans la revendication est
nommément cité c'est françois hollande
c'est à cause de françois hollande les
teros du bataclan quand il capte pas
rapide qu on leur massacre ils disent
voilà vous pourrez remercier votre
présidence des terrains non bon il va
venir mais je pense que on va aussi
entendre bernard cazeneuve qui est émis
de l'intérieur entendre le procureur
molins procureur de la république à
l'époque aujourd'hui encore général près
la cour de cassation je pense que ces
gens se sont déjà énormément exprimer je
pense que
je pense que certaines parties civiles
avocats certains avocats de parties
civiles pour être tentés de
le
faire un petit numéro
2 m et 2 m de cuisine et voilà le
président hollande mon expérience de
chroniqueurs judiciaires le cas présent
c'est que à chaque fois que j'ai qu'un
avocat c'est a eu l'idée de mettre en
difficulté un homme politique de
l'envergure d'après en la république ou
d'un ministre extrêmement brillant jean
pierre chevènement procès des paillotes
incendiés en général ça se retourne
contre le contre l'avocat parce que ces
gens sont d'une
capacité de tes lecteurs importante et
ça fait extrêmement bien
dire ce qu'ils veulent ne pas esquiver
en plus françois hollande est réputé
pour une certaine forme d'humour assez
ironique voilà c'est des
personnalités ont négocié pendant des
nuits entières avec teixido avec poutine
je pense pas qu'un avocat de partie
civile soit de soin d'eux
l'envergure pour le mettre en discute et
on verra bien mais je pense que
c'est des dépositions on va voir encore
une fois mais a priori je vois pas très
bien ce que ça va apporter puisque
françois hollande s'est largement
expliqué sur sur les attentats et
attaques juste titre il était président
de la république à l'époque chef de
l'ugtt à vous y assisterait voilà les
positions du président bah oui les bleus
et poursuivre à votre compte rendu
d'audience du coup stéphane durand
souffland sur sur lefigaro.fr et dans
les pages du figaro merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on se retrouvera
certainement pour un autre point d'étape
sur ce procès des attentats du 13
novembre à très bientôt sur figaro live
merci d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir été
nombreux sur les tchats je salue donc
christian léon toussaint et christophe
de margerie au figaro.fr ainsi que rome
37 91 et sur youtube elhadj djiba darius
xérès et aurélie gallard qui continue de
chat et à bientôt sur figaro life pour
un prochain sujet